[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 se
cumplieron 100 días desde la retoma del
grupo talibán en afganistán con su
interpretación extrema de la sharía o
ley religiosa del país se retrocedió en
derechos humanos y eso ha significado el
silenciamiento de las voces de las
mujeres las niñas están restringidas en
su educación y las adultas no pueden
trabajar todos se perdieron la
independencia que habían recuperado en
20 años además de la comunidad
internacional le retiró la mayoría de
auxilios humanitarios que sostenían al
país y la pobreza en aumento está
llevando a cifras cada vez mayores el
matrimonio infantil un crimen
imperdonable
junto con la pobreza también aumentó el
matrimonio infantil en afganistán desde
que los talibanes tomaron el poder el 15
de agosto
los informes de organizaciones no
gubernamentales relatan la situación de
padres que sin medios de subsistencia
prometen a sus hijas a menudo niñas
pequeñas en matrimonio a cambio de dotes
la predicción es que la tasa de
matrimonio infantil que prevalecía
incluso antes del regreso de los
talibanes podría casi duplicarse en los
próximos meses
y me paraliza el corazón escuchar estas
historias no es un matrimonio es una
violación infantil
frog dijo que las familias estaban
cazando a sus hijas para reducir la
cantidad de bocas que tenían que
alimentar para pagar deudas y para
obtener dotes
la agencia de la onu para la infancia
unicef dijo que había informes creíbles
de familias que ofrecían hijas de hasta
20 días para un futuro matrimonio a
cambio de dinero
según las agencias de naciones unidas el
país paralizado por la sequía y el
colapso económico se convertirá en la
peor crisis humanitaria del mundo
millones están al borde de la inanición
y el 97% de los hogares podrían caer por
debajo del umbral de pobreza para
mediados de 2022 en una nación que con
20 años de guerra a cuestas dependía
casi totalmente de ayudas
internacionales ahora congeladas
antes de que los talibanes tomaran el
poder la edad mínima legal para contraer
matrimonio era de 16 años para las niñas
por debajo del mínimo reconocido
internacionalmente de 18 años
pero el nuevo gobierno solo sigue la ley
sharia que no estipula una edad mínima
los datos nacionales muestran que el 28%
de las niñas en afganistán se casan
antes de los 18 años y el 4% antes de
los 15 pero las menores obligadas a
casarse podrían pasar al 50% si la
crisis continua
las niñas que se casan jóvenes sufren
violación conyugal abuso doméstico
explotación y complicaciones peligrosas
del embarazo
arruina sus vidas su salud psicológica
emocional física y sexual estas
muchachas a menudo son tratadas como
sirvientas como esclavas
el cierre de las escuelas secundarias de
niñas por parte de los talibanes también
empuja a los padres a casar a sus hijas
los dos factores de riesgo más
importantes para impulsar el matrimonio
infantil son la pobreza y la falta de
acceso a la educación
los talibanes que prohibieron la
educación de las niñas cuando estuvieron
en el poder por última vez entre 1996 y
2001 mantienen en suspenso del tema para
conversar sobre este tema está en ellas
hoy maribel de tellado responsable
adjunta del departamento de campañas
para la movilización en amnistía
internacional españa maribel gracias a
ustedes y empecemos hablando de las
iniciativas de las organizaciones unicef
dijo que había iniciado un programa de
asistencia para paliar el hambre y
también el matrimonio infantil e incluso
que estaba en contacto con líderes
religiosos para detener las ceremonias
de menores de edad iniciativas como esta
para usted tienen efectividad cuál es la
acción de amnistía internacional en este
caso
bueno totalmente todas las acciones que
tengan en el centro a las mujeres y en
particular a las niñas hay que darles
valor y hay que apoyarlas como bien has
explicado en el reportaje muy completo
el riesgo para las niñas es mayor en
contextos de pobreza en un estamos en un
contexto en el que se ha retirado
prácticamente toda la financiación toda
la ayuda humanitaria
y teniendo en cuenta que el 43 por
ciento del producto interior bruto del
país dependía de esta ayuda entonces
todos los proyectos que tienen que ver
con procesos de desarrollo de la mujer y
educación
obviamente se han paralizado
sumado a que efectivamente las niñas
mayores de 12 años en su mayoría ya no
pueden ir a la escuela no tienen
prohibido éstos son 4 millones de niñas
en el país
y que las mujeres además no pueden ir a
trabajar con lo cual la situación
económica en muchas familias que ya no
tienen ese salario del ingreso se ha
puesto totalmente en riesgo cómo sumar a
eso además y si si no era escuché el
escucho adelante esto no la falta de
respeto de los talibanes a los derechos
de las mujeres y las niñas en general y
en particular en cuestiones que tienen
que ver con las relaciones con el
matrimonio y bueno es un testimonio de
agosto no día cuando incluso antes de
que los talibán tomaran kabul de una
mujer que tal vez recogiste y secuestro
en nuestro programa también que dijo
cómo los talibán iban casa por casa y
decían que si en una casa había dos
hijas una era para ellos todos forzando
a las niñas a un matrimonio y esclavitud
sexual de por vida probablemente
vamos a hablar el punto por punto los
donantes dicen que quieren utilizar la
ayuda como una palanca para garantizar
que los talibanes defiendan los derechos
de las niñas y de las mujeres sin
embargo lo que está pasando es que esas
niñas las mujeres se están muriendo de
hambre entonces cuál es el llamado en
ese sentido y cuál es la manera correcta
de aportar para la situación en
afganistán
pues desde amistad internacional lo que
pedimos es que se mantengan y se
financien los programas de ayuda a la
financiación para que todas las todas
las personas en afganistán en particular
las mujeres puedan salir adelante pero
esto tiene que ir acompañado de una
exigencia a los talibán del cumplimiento
de los derechos humanos en particular
que permitan a las mujeres volver a
trabajar que permitan a las niñas volver
a la escuela que permitan a las mujeres
participar en la vida pública como
estaban antes en el gobierno ahora
tienen cero representación en digamos de
los estamentos
talibanes entonces tiene que ir
acompañada de esa serie de exigencias en
materia de derechos humanos de derechos
de las mujeres y las niñas y de una
vigilancia también para asegurarse que
efectivamente esas ayudas a través de
organizaciones locales y
organizaciones internacionales pero
tienen una vigilancia que sea segura que
llegan a quienes tienen que llegar pero
desde luego a la misma y una crisis
humanitaria
tremenda catastrófica habéis dicho a las
cifras de pobreza
y poco más hay que añadir a que casi eso
más del 90 por ciento de la población va
a estar en pobreza el año próximo dentro
de unos meses
maribel para las mujeres ella en su
adultez y como usted lo está mencionando
tremendísimos desafíos como se ha visto
por ejemplo afectada la lucha para que
el hiyab no sea una prenda obligatoria
han desaparecido las mujeres de la vida
pública
es lo que intenta se intenta borrar a
las mujeres del espacio público en
general eliminarlas prácticamente de ese
espacio la vestimenta obligatoria es uno
de los elementos y desde luego ha
impactado por ejemplo en el acceso a la
educación superior la educación superior
universitaria aunque no está prohibida
en principio las han sometido a las
mujeres a un sistema de segregación en
el cual sólo las mujeres pueden ser ser
ser digamos enseñadas por mujeres lo
cual limita porque no hay profesoras
universitarias suficientes para todas
las ramas de digamos universitarios
luego tienen miedo también porque se han
visto sometidas a empresarias y luego el
hecho de la de la vestimenta que les
obliga que es un elemento más de todo
este conjunto de represión hacia las
mujeres y las niñas y luego hay muchas
profesiones que lamentablemente
directamente están prohibidas y además
quienes las ejercen están en grave
peligro las periodistas como como tú
eres una de las profesiones más en
riesgo o por ejemplo mujeres policías
que era otra parte importante de la
sociedad porque atendían
y muchos casos de mujeres víctimas de
violencia de género o casos de niñas y
las policías no solamente ya no pueden
trabajar sino que están especialmente
señaladas y desde agosto al menos se han
documentado el asesinato de cuatro
mujeres policías una de ellas incluso
embarazada de ocho meses entonces
realmente la situación es muy
preocupante
muy peligrosa y hay que estar al lado de
las mujeres la comunidad internacional
tiene una responsabilidad tiene que
apoyarlas tiene que estar a su lado y
desde luego escucharlas y no abandonarla
en ningún momento las niñas son vendidas
para pagar deudas pero también en
algunos de los testimonios que han
logrado recoger a agencias
internacionales y también periodistas en
terreno los padres alegan que esta es
también una oportunidad que ellos les
están dando de que sobrevivan porque no
tienen como alimentarlas cómo
mantenerlas como tenerlas en su casa de
familia sin embargo qué es lo que
realmente le espera a una niña esposa
pues te puedes imaginar
desde luego
y ninguna niña puede decirse que esté
casa por su propia voluntad
lo primero que tiene que primar en todos
los casos es la protección de las
menores en este caso y no se está
teniendo en cuenta obviamente
y bueno un matrimonio forzado es un
matrimonio en el que como bien decía es
la violación
es bueno está de alguna manera
establecida no y bueno lamentable porque
además esto va a restringir su derecho a
otras cosas no a la educación por
supuesto ni hablamos de poder trabajar
ahora mismo ya las mujeres no pueden
salir solas de casa sin la compañía de
un varón pero menos a una niña que es
que es casada de manera forzada afecta
completamente a sus derechos sexuales y
reproductivos porque obviamente no
solamente no puede elegir con quién
casarse con quién sí tener o no
relaciones sexuales mucho menos va a
poder elegir si quiere o no tener hijos
cuántos y cuándo
todo esto en un contexto en que hay un
sistema de salud que está
prácticamente desmantelado porque uno
con los problemas asociados que hay a
los embarazos y encima es un embarazo
infantil pues mucho peor no y lo del
sistema de salud desmantelado por
ejemplo parte del impacto de la retirada
de los fondos de la unión europea es que
se han cerrado dos mil centros de salud
en todo el país casi la mitad de la
población no tiene acceso a la salud
pues viene muchísimas gracias a usted
por visibilizar una vez más lo que está
pasando con las mujeres con los derechos
humanos en general en afganistán
nosotros desde aquí seguimos dando la
lucha seguiremos poniendo el tema sobre
la mesa y le deseamos pues mucho éxito
en la misión de su organización para con
afganistán
muchas gracias y ustedes nuestros
televidentes gracias por estar con
nosotros nos vemos próximamente en ellas
hoy y nos seguimos viendo también en
france24
[Música]